Hello everyone,
Adam Reno, Assistant
Professor of Clinical
Medicine at the
Arkansas campus in
Jonesboro, Arkansas
with the New York
Institute of Technology
College of Osteopathic
Medicine coming
to you today to talk
about headaches.
So our session objectives
and the purpose
behind this lecture
is to help you define
primary and secondary
types of headaches and
help you distinguish
between these headaches
according to the IHS
classification system.
Identify different
types of headaches based
on their presentation,
symptoms, causes.
Identify any red flags
in the evaluation
of headaches and
something that would
prompt you to seek
emergent attention.
List treatment options
based on the type
of headaches and what
you would do to help
your patient cope
with their headache.
Throughout the lecture
you're going to find
several URLs that you
can follow for more
information and I do
highly encourage that.
Headaches are a
very disabling
problem for
your patients.
There's a lot of
burden to these,
there's symptom
burdens and
secondary burdens
of headache.
During their
headache, the patient
will have pain and
suffering, leading
to reduced
functional ability.
Between their headaches,
they're going to be
fearful of when their
next headache is going
to attack, and this
can lead to avoidance
of behaviors and also
lifestyle compromise.
during attacks or
headaches they're going
to have loss of work
and time effectiveness
also failed and
abdicated social
roles this could also
lead to breakdown of
relationships cessation
of social planning
and also patients
failing to meet
their full potential
headaches are very
very common and highly
disabling often though
and interestingly
enough headaches
are often misdiagnosed
and under-treated.
I think it comes
down to history and
physical exam and
understanding what
type of headache your
patient is experiencing
and we'll go to
that go into that
a little bit more
in several slides.
Effective treatment
is often possible
but hinges on the
correct diagnosis.
Headaches also
have a very large
differential diagnosis
and so they need
to be approached
systematically.
The IHS system or
the International
Headache Society, they
have a good tool that
you can use and
provide a framework for
headache diagnosis,
and I do recommend
clicking on the link
and following that.
According to the IHS,
there are two different
types of headaches.
In all reality,
there's primary and
secondary headaches.
The primary headaches
that you're going to
see most of in clinic
and as you evaluate
your patients are
tension-type headaches,
migraines, cluster
headaches, and other
trigeminal autonomic
dysephalasias. Your
secondary headaches
Headaches are
normally the ones
that require emergent
attention and workup and
they include infection,
head injuries,
brain masses and
tumors and vascular
disorders and bleeds.
So your primary
headaches are
usually benign
and recurrent,
not usually associated
with underlying
pathology and in
most circumstances
the headache itself
is the disease.
multiple types of
primary headaches again
are include your
migraine with and
without aura your
attention type headaches
there's two different
types of these
that are episodic and
chronic and cluster
headache and other
trigeminal autonomic
syphalgias they include
cluster headaches
paroxysmal hemicrania
your sunk and
also your suna and
hemicrania continua
your secondary headaches
according to the
hsf classification
is the well secondary
headaches can be sudden
and progressive usually
associated with
pathology may require
immediate action they're
usually attributed to
head and neck trauma
substance ***** or
withdrawal thereof
disorders of homeostasis
disorders of the cranium
which can include the
eyes ears nose and
throat teeth other facial
structures they could
be psychiatric they
can be neural they can
be non and intracranial
disorders neurovascular
disorders essentially
and different types
or examples of
secondary headaches
include temporal arteritis
TMJ seizures glaucoma
trauma medication over
use syndrome poisons
and toxins increased
intracranial
hypertension or pressure
meningitis intracranial
neoplasia and so for it.
The cranial neuralgias
and other headaches,
the IHS classification,
they state trigeminal
neuralgia, cold
stimulus headache, and
that's an interesting
one. It's like eating ice
cream too fast, you
experience a headache.
External compression
headaches,
other trigeminal
branch neuralgias,
there's the
glossopharyngeal neuralgia.
After workup and a
full evaluation of
patient, and you
still cannot figure
out what is causing
their headache.
It falls down to
headache, not others who
are classified, or
headache unspecified.
So during your
headache assessment,
well, first of
all, the purpose of
the assessment, I
should say, is to
exclude any urgent,
emergent, and or
serious cause. That
is the purpose.
Make accurate
diagnosis of headache
type so you can
accurately treat it.
And explain the diagnosis
and rationale for
treatment to your
patient, as this will
help them understand
why you're doing what
you're doing assessment
tools several things
that you can use
during your evaluation
of headache would be
history taking physical
exam headache diaries
imaging studies and
laboratory analysis
in all reality a lot
of imaging and laboratory
analysis may not
even be needed because
you can get a lot of
information from history
and physical exam
history taking it
goes to say that this
history taking is the
single most important
tool that you can use
for defining headache
diagnosis and initiating
a treatment plan
some information you want
to gather while you're
performing your
history is onset and
frequency of their
headaches localization
description thereof
the nature of their
pain does the
headache radiate what
side of the head is
the headache on is
it both sides on the
left or the right
predisposing factors
triggering triggers
that cause the
headache exacerbating
factors things that
make the headache
worse response how is
the patient's actions
and limitations
during the headache
are you using any
medications? And if
so, how often? What
type of medications?
Associated symptoms
with their headache,
auras, nausea,
vomiting, photo and
phonophobia, lacrimation,
visual changes.
Does the patient
take any medications?
Something you want to
think about is what
are their comorbidities
the patient has?
Do they have diabetes
and hypothyroidism?
And if so, are
they on correct
medications for this?
And if they are, are
the medications
causing their headache.
Some people with
hypertension get on a
medication like
metoprolol or toprol and
that can lead to several
headaches in some
patients. And so
medications alone,
even prescription
medications can cause
headaches. Are they
using any herbal
supplements over the
counter, alternative
medications, something
that they may not be
telling you when they
come in initially.
One good thing to
ask your patients is
not only are you
prescribed any medications,
but what herbal
supplements and
alternative medications
are you taking? Have
they tried new foods
recently? What are
their eating habits?
Are they exercising?
What's their stress
and anxiety level?
Do they smoke
tobacco? Do they drink
alcohol? Do they use
any drugs or caffeine?
Another thing is
asking about their
allergies. If they're
allergic to dogs
and they have several
dogs in the home,
is that the cause
of their headache?
Any surgeries?
If they had any sinus
surgery in the past
have they had any
other ear nose and
throat surgeries in
the past any trauma are
there any triggers
to their headache
ask them about their
diet they again alcohol
use chocolate caffeine
nuts aspartame
hormones are a big
leading cause of
headaches so
asking about menses
ovulation are they on
a oral contraceptive
pills hormone
replacement therapy.
Are they under
a lot of stress?
Some headaches are
caused by stress.
Are they going
through a death or
divorce, a death in
the family, or are they
going through a
divorce? Are they
moving? Are they
relocating for a job?
Is there a change
in habits that they
normally have? For
example, their diet,
their sleep, physical
activity. Is the
weather causing them
to have a headache?
and on your physical
exam some things you
want to look at for
headache are blood
pressure for sure
and other vital signs
including temperature
body mass index you want
to do a complete head
eyes ears nose and
throat exam inspecting
the temporal artery
you want to inspect
it and you also want
to palpate it as
well make sure that's
not the cause of their
headache and are there
any signs of upper
respiratory tract
infections that can be
leading to headache.
I'm going to
do a neck exam
looking for
meningeal signs,
auscultation for
carotid bruise, a
fundoscopic exam
on a neurological
status, mental
status exam,
coordination, gait,
depression screening.
Back to headache diary
for a second here.
Here's a good example
of what a headache
diary can look like.
Patients can record
what date they're having
their headaches on
when the headache
began and when it ended
do they use any
medications for the pain
and if so what type
of medication and what
dosage the hours of
sleep that they had
what they ate throughout
the day location of
their headache and
also the intensity
thereof this can be a
very useful tool if the
patient brings this
into the clinic because
you can look at this
and come up with a
treatment plan one
specific example would
be migraines There are
several medications
that are approved for
migraines. However,
a lot of them require
a headache diary
prior to initiation of
the medicine itself.
Speaking of
migraine, migraine
headaches are one
of your primary
headaches, and they
affect about 12%
to 15% of the
general population.
And they do affect
females more than males,
up to 17% in females
and up to 6% in
males. And one of the
interesting things
about migraines is
there is a large family
history of this.
They're present in about
70% of cases, and Aura
with your migraine
usually occur in
about 5% of migraines.
Migraine headache
is primarily
a neuronal dysfunction.
It was initially
thought, interestingly
enough, that
it was due to
dilation of blood
vessels. However, this
has been proven
to be incorrect.
Now they're thinking
it's more due to
cortical spreading depression
and cell-propagating
wave of neuronal and
glial depolarization
spreading across
the cerebral cortex.
Because of this,
it causes the aura,
the migraine, activation
of the trigeminal
nerve afferents,
and also alters
the blood-brain
barrier permeability.
There are four
different types
of phases in a
migraine attack,
the prodrome, aura,
pain, and prostrome.
the prodrome there
are array of symptoms
that a patient may be
experiencing during
this time for example
some people become
very very talkative
some patients become
very irritable some
people will be very
thirsty some patients
will be urinating
more frequently some
patients are having
photophobia and
phonophobia so it's really
across the board
when it comes to
different symptoms but
it is a good idea to
find out what symptoms
your patient has.
The RFAs appears
usually 5 to 20 minutes
and usually lasts
less than 60 minutes
during a migraine.
This can be visual,
sensory, or motor
in nature and it
is actually the
most common type of
neurological event in
about 90% of cases.
Migraine headaches are
typically unilateral
and I'll show you
a picture here in a
second of where they
can be located on the
head. Throbbing,
moderate to severe pain
and aggravated by
physical activity they're
usually gradual in
onset and usually peak
in about four to 72
hours in adults and
one to 48 hours in
children they are normally
accompanied by
nausea in 90 of the
cases and vomiting
is only in 30 of the
cases it is common to
have photo and phonophobia
with migraines and
also osmophobia
this is a picture of
where migraines are
normally located not
specifically to the
right side of the face
like in this patient's
example but can be on
the left as well but
it's normally unilateral
and the patient can
come in one of the most
important things that
you can ask him is to
have them take their
finger and point to
their head where they're
experiencing their
migraine or their headache
the post room symptom
or phase of the
attack, the patient is
usually tired and listless.
They can have mood
changes and tenderness
in the scalp area
where the migraine was.
Interestingly enough,
some patients will feel
unusually refreshed
and euphoric, whereas
some others report
depression and malaise.
And in some patients, the
headache phase
can continue.
Now, migraine without
ARA, the diagnostic
criteria for this
is an attack lasting
four to 72 hours
having occurred at
least five times and
must have two of the
following criteria
unilateral pulsating
moderate to severe
and aggravated by
exercise it also
must have one of the
following nausea
photophobia or phonophobia
migraine with aura
diagnostic criteria is
a migraine without
aura plus one of the
more the focal
neurological signs such as
visual, sensory, aphasia,
motor, and gradual
development of RA
symptoms. The RA usually
lasts 4 to 60 minutes
followed by or
accompanied by headache
within 60 minutes.
Some factors or
triggers that can really
predispose a
migraine headache are
number one, of course,
is family history.
It's a big one to
ask your patients.
History of
travel sickness,
menstruation, so going
back to menses and
ovulation, hormonal
replacement therapy,
are they on any
oral contraceptive
pills, have they
had any trauma
to their head
or their neck,
have they
recently performed
any strenuous exercise,
ask them about their
diet, again, chocolate,
cheese, aspartame,
alcohol, this is
usually less than 10%
of triggers, however,
smells such as
perfumes and gasoline
can lead to migraine
headaches as well,
Commonly, you'll see
in clinics that you'll
see signs that show
that they recommend that
you do not wear perfumes
or fragrances in
an effort to avoid
headaches and other symptoms
in patients that
present to the clinic.
Loud noises and
bright lights can
predispose patients
for migraines
and also change
in habits such as
missing meals, not
sleeping enough.
acute treatment of
migraines some basic
principles to understand
and know for sure are
getting the correct
dose the correct
formulation as well and
then step up treatment so
you first start with
simple analgesia then
you do combination
medications then you go
to your trip down your
guts early intervention
or treatment for
acute migraines is key
and you want to use
the medication at least
three times before
judging effectiveness.
So often do patients
get put on a medication,
they take it once
and they say, this
medication is not
effective, it did not help.
Have them try at
least three times the
medicine before
they say, you know
what, it's not going
to work for you.
Use a maximum
of two to three
days per week or
eight days a month
for some of these
medications.
Some examples of
acute treatment are
some of your
analgesics include your
Tylenol and your
NSAIDs, ibuprofen.
Specific anti
-migraine medications
or therapies include
your triptans,
which is your
sumatriptan, your
risotriptan, your
ergots, ergotamine.
Anti-emetics can
be very helpful in
migraines as well
because your patients
will be experiencing
nausea and
vomiting, so
promethazine or fenugrin.
There's compazine,
and there's also
metoclopramide
that can be used.
Combination
medications, one of the
medications that is
very effective in
migraines for patients
can be Excedrin.
It has Tylenol,
Aspirin, and Caffeine.
And when you're
thinking about migraine
headaches, one of the
big questions you should
ask yourself is how can
I prevent a migraine
from coming all
together and having your
patients not experiencing
or have them have
experienced less
migraine days per month.
Some things to
help with this are
lifestyle
modifications. Have
your patients get
regular sleep.
Have them eat regular
meals throughout the
day drink a moderate
amount of water get
some good exercise limit
their caffeine alcohol
and other drugs and
try to reduce stress
as much as possible
a lot of these can be
very taxing for
patients and are very
difficult such as
reducing stress cognitive
behavioral therapy and
biofeedback are also
very important you
could also do some
relaxation training some
OMT acupuncture and then
there's pharmacological
treatment as well
so when to use
pharmacological treatment
you want to use
for prevention usually
if frequent headaches
occur more than three
to four months three
to four headaches
a month migraine
significantly interferes
with patients daily life
despite abortive treatment
and acute abortive
therapies contraindicated
ineffective
or not tolerated or
overused some prescription
treatments include
antihypertensives.
You can place them on
propranolol, natalol.
There's calcium channel
blockers that you
can use, such as
verapamil and amlodipine.
Antidepressants are
also very, very helpful.
Venlafaxine is one of
them. Amitriptyline,
your tricyclic
antidepressants can
be helpful for
migraine prophylaxis.
Anticonvulsants, such as
Depakote and Naproxen.
and some of your
cgrps as well those
are your calcium
gene related peptides
um nertech amovig and
gallida you probably
they're more of your
newer agents that have
been used for migraines
recently and they're
very effective i've
had several patients
personally myself that
have been on these
medications and they've
gone from 15 to 20
migraine days a month
down to one to two
migraine days per month
these medications are
the medicines that
you'll need to have your
headache diary for so
that you have evidence
that yes your patients
are experiencing
less migraines because
of these medications
or and also another
good tool or caveat to
remember is keep a
log of the medications
that they've tried
for their migraines so
for example if they've
been on propranolol
and then they started
ibuprofen and Tylenol
that's not helpful and
you've tried Maxalt
and you've tried
sumatriptan and none of the
medications are helpful
you can say that
they failed multiple
medicines now it might
be beneficial to try
a CGRP medicine again
some general
principles for migraine
headaches is to consider
comorbidities and
lifestyle factors
titrate the dose again
start low and go slow
aim for their optimal
dose try medication
for at least three
months if possible
and some patients may
relapse and require
a long-term therapy
i like this picture here
it actually was used
in the lecture prior
to me updating the
lecture for headaches
and i kept it in for a
good reason it gives
you an idea that as a
physician you walk in
there have the patient
point out to where their
headache is it'd be
nice if everybody walked
into the clinic and
it was straightforward
like this that yes
you don't have a migraine
this is what it is
but just remember to
get an accurate history
from your patients and
they'll lead you into
the diagnosis so now
your tension type
headaches again this
goes into your primary
headache types and this
is actually the most
common type of headache
that you're going to be
seeing your patients
experience there are
two different types of
tension type headaches
there's episodic and
there's chronic and
we'll go into that here
in a second the tension
type headaches affect
women more than men
they're usually mild
to moderate in severity
genetics really only
play a minor role
in tension type headaches
unlike migraines
where genetics play
quite a bit and they
last as little as
30 minutes but they
can be as persistent
as seven days
myofascial tenderness is
increased some patients
may have tension
type headaches that
coexist with their
migraine headache.
Some triggers
include stress,
fatigue, and
lack of sleep.
And interestingly
enough, tension-type
headaches are found to
be in greater than 50
% of patients with
depression and anxiety.
How these work, well,
we really don't know.
Likely multifactorial
and episodic tension
-type headaches.
They're thinking
maybe the peripheral
activation or
sensitization
sensitization of myofascial
nociceptors. For
chronic, sensitization of
pain pathways in
the central nervous
system due to prolonged
nociceptive stimuli
from pericranial
myofascial tissues.
Nitric oxide may play a
role in these headaches.
This is currently
under study, and again,
genetic factors may
play a role for chronic,
but they're definitely
not episodic tension
type headaches causing
release back their
headaches the International
Headache Society
criteria for tension
type headaches require
at least 10 episodes of
headache each lasting
30 minutes to 7 days
which fulfill the
following conditions
at least two of the
following bilateral location
pressing or tightening
non-pulsive pulsating
quality mild and
moderate intensity and
are not aggravated by
route or aggravated by
routine activity such
as walking or climbing
stairs and must have
both of the following
as well no nausea or
vomiting and no more
than one of photophobia
or phonophobia if your
patient walks into your
office and says i'm
having a headache and
they put their hand
across their forehead and
say my headache is
right here and it feels
like there's a band
that's wrapping around
my head that's a good
segue into this may be
a tension type headache
and you can further
evaluate that and
determine if this is the
type of headache that
your pain or your patient
is experiencing some
patients will get pain
and spasm in their
cervical spine musculature
as you can see in
this picture that may
not always be the
case for some patients
episodic tension type
headaches they're episodic
which means they are
not chronic, and they
usually are less than
15 headaches a month.
Initial treatment
for these are
your NSAIDs or
aspirin, Tylenol.
Some parenteral
medications are
usually used in
severe cases. They
include Toradol,
Metoclopramide, and
there's limited
evidence for this.
Chronic tension
type headaches. Your
patients come in, they're
having greater than
15 headache days a
month, and this has
been going on for
greater than six months.
Some treatments for
that can include Tylenol
and ibuprofen
or other NSAIDs.
Amitriptyline, skeletal
muscle relaxants,
fluoxetine. Some big
things that you can use
are OMT. You'll
learn some techniques
throughout your training
on how to help with
chronic tension type
headaches. Physical
therapy, massage,
acupuncture, and stress
management in general
can help with this.
Back to tension type
headache for a minute.
I've actually had some
patients where I've
had to refer over to
neurology and they've
successfully undergone
several injections into
the base of their neck
near the occiput to
help release on the
musculature which is
causing some tension in
their neck leading to
their tension type
headache. This has been
helpful. Some people
have done Botox as well
which has been helpful
for their headaches.
Cluster headache is
another one of your
primary headaches
and age of onset is
usually 25 to 50 years
of age, and these
ones affect males
more than females,
unlike your tension
type headaches and
migraines, which are
female more than male.
Diagnostic criteria
for this is, well,
most of the attacks
are clustered in
time, so hence the
name cluster headache.
They can be severe
unilateral, orbital,
superorbital, and or
temporal pain. The
duration is usually
15 minutes to about
3 hours, and occur 1
to 8 times per day.
They're normally
associated with one
of the following
ipsilateral signs.
One of the board
questions that you
need to remember
when it comes into a
cluster headache
is someone comes in
and they have a
headache that's usually
unilateral,
affecting their eye,
and they're tearing
out of their eye.
That is a big clue
for a cluster-type
headache. They can have
eyelid edema, forehead
and facial swelling,
meiosis and ptosis,
and they're usually
restless and agitated.
Here's a great picture
of a cluster headache.
Again, pain around
the orbital area.
They could have
ptosis and meiosis.
Tearing and lacrimation,
nasal stuffiness
and discharge is
another finding.
Again, like tension
-type headaches,
incompletely understood.
They're complex.
The most widely accepted
theory is hypothalamic
activation with
secondary activation
of the trigeminal
autonomic reflex, likely
via the trigeminal
hypothalamic pathway.
another accepted
theory behind cluster
headache is neurogenic
inflammation of the
walls of the cavernous
sinus obliterates
venous outflow which
injures the traversing
sympathetic fibers
that intracranial
internal carotid artery
in its branches so
it's still under a
lot of research trying
to figure out exactly
what causes this now
treatment in the cute
fan an acute cluster
headache is usually
100% oxygen you can
also do subcutaneous
or nasal triptans
that can be helpful
for cluster headaches.
For chronic cluster
headaches and
preventative treatment,
you can use verapamil,
lithium, steroids,
and anticonvulsants.
I wanted to
put this table
into the lecture today.
It kind of breaks
it down. Everything
we've been talking
about thus far,
this is a good way
to look at location,
characteristics,
duration, symptoms,
patient appearance
of your three
primary headaches,
migraine, tension,
headache, and
cluster headache.
Here is another chart
to look at here, or
diagram, that will show
you headache patterns.
And I thought this to
be very beneficial.
As you can see at the
very bottom, brain
tumor, the pain starts
off very small, but
gets more severe as
time progresses and
doesn't have a waxing
or waning period.
Cluster headaches are
clustered in time. You
have the headache,
goes away, comes back.
Tension headache
is pretty much
constant. It's not
going to get worse. It's
not going to get
better. It's just
going to stay the
same. and migraine
headaches come and
go periodically.
So now into
some secondary
headache examples.
So we just talked
about your primary
headaches, now we're
in secondary headaches.
Some examples of
this are medication
overuse, sinus
headaches, glaucoma,
Chiari malformation,
seizures,
meningitis, hypertension,
lumbar puncture
headache, dialysis
headache, temporal
arteritis.
So as you can see,
there's a lot
of different
etiologies behind
secondary headaches.
Some red flags to
look for when you have
someone come in with a
headache would be sudden
onset or they say,
this is the worst
headache of my life, the
thunderclap headache.
If the patient is
50 years of age
and older and they've
never experienced
a headache in
their life and now
they're coming in
with a very severe
headache, that's
a big red flag.
History of recent trauma.
Are they currently
anticoagulated? Do
they have a history
of atrial fibrillation
or pulmonary embolism
and they're on a
blood-thinning medicine
and now they have
a severe headache?
That's a red flag.
Are there any
systemic signs such
as fevers, myalgias,
any weight loss
that the patient
is experiencing?
Systemic disease.
Do they have cancer?
Do they have HIV?
What about if they
change their posture?
Is their headache
different when they're
sitting up as opposed
to laying down?
When they're coughing
or bearing down
to have a bowel
movement, are they having
a headache with
that? Are they having
a headache when
they have an ******?
Is there any
change in frequency
and severity of
their headaches?
And do they have
any altermentation
or focal neurological
findings?
Some of the secondary
headaches that
we're going to cover
today now, we're
not going to cover
every one of them.
However, I just
wanted to cover six
of the major ones
that you will see
throughout your
training and career.
first being your
subarachnoid hemorrhage.
Subarachnoid hemorrhages
are usually the
result of a ruptured
cerebral arterial
aneurysm, or AVM,
arteriovenous malformation.
70% of the time it's a
saccular bary aneurysm.
And it usually
occurs in ages 50
to 60 with an equal
*** distribution.
It doesn't matter
if you're male
or a female, it's
usually equal.
This may be
familial in some
cases, but most
arise sporadically.
The classic
presentation for this
is sudden onset,
unusually severe
generalized
headache described
as the worst
headache of my life.
If your patient
comes in and they're
explaining this,
that yes, this is the
worst headache of
my life, it feels
like thunder just
went off in my head,
you want to get
a CT scan of
their brain
without contrast.
You also want to
ensure that your
blood pressure is
controlled to a
certain degree and
also get neurosurgery
involved as soon
as possible.
Here is the intracranial
aneurysm frequency
distribution. As you
can see, the middle
cerebral artery is at
29%, so it takes the
number one area of
where these can occur,
followed by the
internal carotid
artery at 16%
and your anterior
communicating
artery at 50%.
CT scans of the head
showing that there is
some bleeding in the
brain and aneurysms.
Intracerebral hemorrhage.
These headaches
are usually
associated with
vocal neurological
deficits, altered
consciousness,
vomiting, and severe
head pain. pain.
The pain comes
from compression of
structures by the
hematoma itself.
Back to this here.
So epidural and
subdural hematomas.
So intracerebral
hemorrhage are one
thing, hematomas, but
into the epidural and
subdural, a lot of
times the epidural
bleed will be really
severe sudden onset and
it will cause a
headache and the patient
may go home and
decompensate unfortunately
and those are the ones
that you need to take
good caution of if they
get hit in the head
with a baseball for
example or a baseball
bat or some other item
or they fall hit their
head subdural hematomas
they can go days and
days and days with
worsening headache
symptoms and you finally
do a CT of their brain
you find out yes
they've had a subdural
hematoma and the pain
that they're experiencing
the reason I bring
this up is because the
pain that they're having
is by the compression
of the structures of
by the hematoma itself
then there's meningitis
and encephalitis
or encephalitis combination
of a new headache
with neck stiffness
fever and altered
mental state should point
you in the direction
of meningitis or
encephalitis infection
involving the brain
parenchyma encephalitis
presents similarly
with headache fever and
altered consciousness
but seizures are frequent
in encephalitis while
they're only five
percent in meningitis
they're sixty percent in
encephalitis pain is
caused by inflammation
of the intracranial pain
sensitive structures
including blood
vessels at the base of
the brain commonly
throbbing in character
bilateral and occipital
or nuchal in location.
Something to watch
out for in many
patients that come in.
They look ill, they've
been having fevers,
and they just
aren't thinking
straight. You may want to
think about meningitis
or encephalitis.
There's your lumbar
puncture headaches. Let's
say one of your
patients come into the
clinic and they say,
I've recently had an
epidural, or I recently
had a c-section, they
did an epidural and
now I have a headache.
You want to consider a
lumbar puncture headache.
This is characterously
a postural
headache with increase
in pain in the
upright position and
the patient actually
has some relief
with recumbents.
This usually occurs
within 48 to 72 hours
after procedure itself
and normally lasts
one to two days. However,
I've seen these last
for several weeks in
some patients, but
however, the symptoms
do improve with time.
Treatment for this is a
blood patch and caffeine.
Then there's giant cell
temporal arteritis.
This is a systemic
vasculitis that
affects medium-sized
and large arteries,
the temporal
artery, especially
branches of the
external carotid artery.
Inflammation of the
pain sensed of arterial
wall produces the
headache and arterial
stenosis leads to
ischemia. This affects
women more than men
and is uncommon before
60 years of age so
if you have a 25 year
old woman who walks
in and says I have
a headache on my right
temple area it may
not be giant cell
temporal arthritis however
you still have to
have it in your
differential most
common symptom is a new
nonspecific headache
unilateral or bilateral
and is often fairly
severe and boring in
quality sedimentation
rate is normally
elevated but not
invariably, and does require
prompt evaluation to
avoid vision loss.
Diagnosis is usually
made by biopsy
of the unaffected
temporal artery,
which is characterously
thickened,
non-pulsatile,
dilated, and tender.
Intracranial masses, they
do cause
headaches as well.
New onset of
headache in the
middle, headache
in middle or late
loss, you always
raise a concern.
And 50% of
patients with brain
tumor complain
of headaches.
Again, 50% of
these patients
complain of headaches.
Characteristically,
it's bifrontal, worse
ipsilaterally, and
aggravated by a
change in position by
maneuvers that increase
intracranial
pressure, such as
coughing, sneezing,
and straining at stool.
Classically,
maximal on awakening
in the morning and
is associated with
nausea and vomiting.
So, throughout this
lecture, the main things
that I wanted you
to glean from the
lecture itself was,
number one, to define
primary and secondary
types of headaches,
which I think we went
through fairly well.
Distinguish
between primary and
secondary headaches
according to
the IHS
classification system.
Identify the
different types
of headaches
based on their
presentation
symptoms and causes.
Identify red flags in the
evaluation of headaches.
and another important
thing is to list
treatment options
based on the type of
headache itself here's
some resources for you
if you want to
look up some of the
information that we
just discussed today and
again my contact
information is here my
office hours vary every
Thursday and Friday
via in person or
zoom so please email
call texts and for
exact dates and we can
get together and discuss
further thank you
for watching this
lecture if you have
any questions feel
free to reach out to me
Thank you.